on est confiné ans mais alain comment
allez vous je ne m'en fous pas
habituellement après je dis je m'en fous
là je m'en fous pas j'espère avant que
ça va bien parce que les temps soient un
peu chelou gamme
il ya trois semaines on avait parlé du
corps d'un virus n'avait pas être pas
mal de choses n'étaient revenus sur tout
ce qui s'était passé finalement avant
d'être en plein dedans là depuis des
semaines on avait parlé entre d'ailleurs
des gens complètement inconscients qui
sortent et qui s'en foutent et alors
qu'ils avaient déjà eu des instructions
mais heureusement en trois semaines les
choses ont changé et évolué et les gens
se sont assagis croirait presque que le
confinement est terminée on peut pas
s'était enfermé il faut sortir quand
même ça y est vous avez coché quoi j'ai
coché par sortie en cash et physique
j'ai marché commun mine de rien je sais
je sais c'est rageant mais faut dire que
ça reste une minorité mais c'est très
rageant
le comportement des gens face au virus
fait plus bas dès que le virus lui même
c'est grave
je sais que le confinement c'est
déprimant c'est relou ça nous prive du
soleil voir ses amis d'aller en terrasse
d'aller au ciné de toutes ses activités
trop cool mais en revanche on a rien à
faire du coût et du coup ça a boosté la
créativité de beaucoup beaucoup de gens
qui ont fait des trucs juste trop bien
depuis que le conflit ne prendra était
bien en place on est cloîtrée chez nous
pendant des semaines et des semaines
c'est l'occasion de prendre du recul et
de faire ce qu'on n'a pas le temps de
faire habituellement au quotidien par
exemple apprendre à jouer d'un
instrument de musique d'apprendre le
piano ou je sais pas je cet exemple
revient beaucoup cet exo jeudi que sa
jeune et que cette idée en fait se met
au dessin faire des activités manuelles
bref tout ça moi par exemple normalement
je commande beaucoup à manger où je vais
beaucoup au restaurant dans vos
quotidiens et là du coup j'ai dû
apprendre à me faire à manger quoi tous
les jours midi et soir
ça ne m'était pas arrivé depuis genre
mais quinze ans ça vraiment et je me
suis rendu compte que j'avais des
lacunes folle je sais pas faire des yeux
c'est bon ou pas mais j'ai la chance
d'être vu par beaucoup de gens donc j'ai
eu droit à pas mal de conseils des
conseils à ses basiques comme par
exemple met du beurre dans la poêle
avant de lancer une cuisson ok tu es
baisse reste tranquille c'est bref hier
là j'ai carrément fait des yeux
brouillés et j'étais trop fier alors
c'est nul à faire c'est simple de fou
mais j'étais fier c'est pas un fan la
vie que je me faisais des oeufs
brouillés s'écroule j'adore les pâtes et
le riz mais j'avoue bout d'un moment ça
fait du bien de changer quoi ça fait du
bien je souffre bref aujourd'hui faisons
un petit tour de tout ce que les gens
ont mis en place pour s'occuper durant
ce confinement et vous allez voir ça va
nous donner un smile fou on commence
avec race incroyable question pour un
balcon
si c'est ce que je pense je suis à deux
doigts d'en ménager là-bas pour le
vivant excusez moi mais c'est génial
o les gens qui crient en choeur balcon
je trouve ça fabuleux effet des petites
blaye fait de cublac sympa
sympa d'avoir d'animateurs qui habite
dans sa rue en plein confinement je
rappelle c'est fou hockey et qui perd
versus équipe un père assez logique
assez intuitif bien joué s'est bien
retrouvé mais comment il sait qui a dit
les bonnes réponses en premier c'est
impossible ils sont à des maîtres des
maîtres au cas despres en hyper au
sérieux ce jeu vraiment la vitre un peu
moyen wii qui l'a dit en premier du coup
c'est le cas au ton jeu je comprends pas
que l'intégralité du bâtiment ne soit
pas sa fenêtre là c'est le meilleur
passe temps ci avait ça chez moi je le
ferai directe ou via les ondes wifi je
l'étais moi mais c'était moi de
merde c'était moi ma boss s'est
transformé en patates au sein de notre
meeting microsoft et n'arrivait pas à
désactiver le filtre elle était donc
bloqué comme ça pendant toute victime
[Musique]
ce qui me fait rester les deux gars qui
se contrôle pour ne pas se moquer il son
self contrôle permanent c'était la pire
réunion de leur vie ils jouaient leur
renvoie la sueur ça mdr mais a besoin
son cd craquelé j'empêche quoi
[Musique]
c'est hubert it qui rame mais les
chenilles à saint génis et continue de
bosser et il sait qu'il va croiser
personne il au milieu de l'eau il a tout
compris
c'est pas une ville magnifique du tout
c'est une ville de génie année
l'ambition à tous nos besoins soient
éteintes au creusot
j'adore je sens que c'est une blague
c'est sûr mais ça me fait rire parce
qu'il ya vraiment des gens qui sont
bornées comme ça ça me tue de rire pas
mal mais je suis sûr que
psychologiquement ça fait du bien de fou
même si c'est pour de faux je suis sûr
que ça fait trop du bien et lâcher les
ont maintenant elle fait un parcours et
le premier chat qui renverse un truc et
l'a perdu
on en est là pour s'occuper
on en est là pour s'occuper et affleure
meilleurs bars en plus oui exemple
typique de ce que le confinement
génèrent les gens vont mettre beaucoup
d'énergie dans des choses dans
lesquelles il n'aurait jamais mis
d'énergie avant que ce qu'ils avaient
autre chose à faire j'ai l'air tout le
monde est prêt à tout pour s'occuper
quitte à faire les trucs les moins
amusant du monde en temps normal c'est
fou
[Musique]
j'ai des flashs back à plusieurs moments
de c'était vraiment moi et 15 ans
sauf que mathieu est à l'air d'avoir 19
fait un support olala cette pauvre maman
en détresse elle ainsi sur les pc con
mais je sais que ma mère il faisait ça
c'est que j'étais mort mort
il vient de mes jeunes amis les temps de
remercier le soldat mature qui s'est
sacrifié au front pour nous proposer un
divertissement sans précédent merci
soldats mathieu ton sacrifice n'a pas
été vain
merci beaucoup je sais que t'es foutu à
l'heure actuelle le taux confinement se
passait bien battu probablement plus
maintenant quoi jeu mathieu ça y est
nouveau complexe
après mon skin en pâte à modeler mon île
sur animal crossing c'est mes voisins on
n'a pas les mêmes voisins
c'est clair tant d'énergie pour une
vidéo j'adore mais j'avoue ça ferait
vraiment envie d'avoir un jardin quoi et
encore je me plains mais moi j'ai un
appart vraiment grands dont je suis
vraiment pas le plus à plaindre
en plus il fait beau allez je vais dans
un parc c'est juste une fois c'est pas
grave ça va rien changer juste une fois
c'est pas les oiseaux qui étaient
habitués à se faire nourrir par les gens
dans les rues ne trouvaient plus
personne en raison du confinement
regarder leurs réactions à tandis qu'une
fois mais regardez leurs réactions on
est vraiment un article pita clic a du
coup ils vont suivre on entend trop
mignon dès qu'il voit un humain ils le
suivent à mort en espérant avoir que de
la bouffe on sait où ces dames ce genre
de phénomène ça lui fait une aura de
puissance quand il ya des oiseaux qui
tourne autour d'elle tout le temps
tellement elle est allée les forces mais
regarde c'est quoi ça sue c'est
clairement un level 200 dans dofus là
deux semaines d'isolation et on est là à
fabriquer des tables de pique nique pour
écureuils parce qu'on est incroyable oh
oh c'est trop bien
c'est la chose la plus adorable j'ai vu
depuis début du confinement c'est trop
bien on en avait parlé mais ça m'énerve
quoi au québec là les québécois a lâché
qui adore 6% des vues lassé des
québécois de cette vidéo vous avez des
raccoon la mignonne petite cet animal
londres ils ont 18 curieux nous on a des
pigeons frère c'est chiant je sais que
mon père il a un jardin et s'occupe de
hérisson il ya des hérissons qui
viennent tout en manger dans son jardin
voilà un big up à paris steria cette
vidéo tu étais aussi confiné c'est sûr
tu regrettes tu t'ennuies d'ailleurs tu
vas bien pas tout roule
est-ce que ça va on est en vidéo mais ce
panneau je prends des news annoncé son
anniversaire mais c'est inné en
quarantaine au nom non la dernière une
brise le coeur c'est la pire ça me fait
penser à celle c'était son anniv pendant
le confinement et du coup on n'a pas pu
le fêter
du coup on lui a juste fait une vidéo en
guise de cadeau et stetrice jours et qui
fait qu'on le fait
abdeslam seconde allez pour vous
voilà le genre de cadeau consommer c'est
bon courage un énorme bisou à tous ceux
qui fêtent leur indépendance le
confinement grosse force à vous et vous
en faites pas vous rattraperez ça la
sortie du confinement j'en suis sûre ce
sera même mieux vous ferez des
anniversaires commun avec tous ceux dont
c'était l'anniversaire pendant la
quarantaine et safra défaite encore plus
grosses avec encore plus de kif
voilà c'est tellement rassurant
[Musique]
à ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta des millions
de gens se sont battus à travers le
monde pour obtenir du pq par peur de ne
plus pouvoir se torcher et toi toi tu
l'utilisent pour faire une fausse
machines à sous à l'écart toi maman
apparemment la quarantaine de ce gaz
passe à merveille comment ça et ol pas
forcément le mieux que la nôtre sa
quarantaine on attend juste s'ils se
rate
il se mange l'une des choses que tu as
le moins envie de te manger dans sa vie
à savoir démarche
c'est fou mais que fais pas ça face à
des marges face à face à un matelas ou
un matelas posé sur des marchés la
limite j'angoisse pour lui pour de vrai
et en plus il sait faire des et
en plus c'est faire du skate vas-y stop
stop stop stop stop stop jama barre de
jalousie on était là il a sorti la
figure en skate on est passé à aller
c'est charles et en plus ils avaient un
point de charisme en plus avec ses
cheveux longs là bas moi je joue à
league of legends doit faire quoi mais
tu vas faire quoi
eh bien écoutez je propose qu'on finisse
sur cette note très positive bon
j'espère les vidéos vous aura plu moi ça
m'a mis un petit coup de boost en vrai
je suis content je suis un peu déçu
aucune vidéo de cuisine je suis le seul
à découvrir la cuisine grâce au
confinement tout le monde connaissait
déjà
voilà évidemment on sera peut-être les
prochains jours une vidéo omegle où vous
me montrez ce que vous faites tourner en
votre confinement si vous avez appris à
danser si vous avez appris à dessiner si
vous avez rénover votre chambre jean
syrien toutes sortes de trucs je pense
qu enfin je trouve ça assez cool de
faire des vidéos on voit pendant
confinement est aussi je pense du coup
forcément la prochaine vidéo activités
manuelles ce serait une vidéo où on fait
de la cuisine
j'essaie de faire une vidéo juge fait
autre chose que du riz des pâtes et des
oeufs
c'est un vrai challenge pour moi mais je
pense ça pousse ça peut être drôle voilà
sinon quand tu es de rester chez vous
évidemment rester chez vous rester
confinés et prenez soin de vous et de
vos proches
et puis voilà tout ça sera j'espère
bientôt fini en tout cas gros ce soir ça
vous j'espère que ce confinement vous
est favorable sur pas mal de choses même
si psychologiquement c'est un peu relou
quand sortira de là plus fort c'est ça
qu'il faut se dire et puis je sais
c'était trop cool de voir tout ce que
les gens font pour un confinement
ça m'a fait du bien je vous dis à
bientôt et c'est chiant
[Musique]